I never know why I already know who hey
youtubers is Charlie since we're only a
couple days away from the Doctor Who
Christmas special I thought it was time
to start the long cry goodbye by doing
my top 11 Matt Smith moments starting on
Sunday I'm also going to start a week of
Doctor Who and Sherlock vids in addition
to a lot of my year and best of lists so
be sure to subscribe to get everything
so let's get started Geronimo number 11
Amelia pond wishes for policeman in the
eleventh hour this really helps set the
tone for Matt Smith's doctor as more of
a low-key trickster figure than the
tenant or Eccleston doctors ever were
people always joke about how Doctor Who
is a show made for children but because
children have been watching it for so
long most of the audience are adults now
in one single moment Amelia pond wishes
the doctor into her backyard making him
the universe's best imaginary friend and
despite all the bad things that happened
during his run I always thought of him
like a cartoon angel and devil sitting
on your shoulders telling you to do
something really good and really bad at
the same time you will always get in
trouble but you will have so much fun
doing it number 10 the doctor's speech
during rings of akhaten this was one of
those sad moments despite it being this
epic speech you listen to the doctor
pour out all of his pain and anguish to
this celestial entity it was like a
death by feels moment the other
important thing about the scene was that
it really lets you know how much the
doctor needs his companions if it was
his job to heal little Amelia pond as
she grew up that it was really Clara's
job to heal him number 9 Amy's choice
and the ballet yard I've seen a lot of
you guys commenting that you think that
Peter Capaldi is going to be the valley
yard but I would argue that Toby Jones
is the closest thing we've seen to him
during Matt Smith's run the doctor even
calls him a dark version of himself even
though technically he was a figment of
everyone's imagination I think that
making him imaginary just left Steven
Moffat a backdoor to cast someone else
as the valley art in the future if he
ever decided - in case you're wondering
I don't think that Peter Capaldi is the
volume number eight Amy Pond gets left
behind during the girl who waited this
was like Amelia ponds 11th hour moment
all over again the whole episode was one
of Amy's darkest timelines next - Angels
Take Manhattan the difference that makes
it really heartbreaking is that it
forces you to see how the experience is
twisted her over time you learn one of
the saddest lessons of Doctor Who the
doctor will always endure but his
companions do not so despite having all
of time and space to play in the price
for admission to the TARDIS is absolute
be sure to take note of that for anyone
who's planning on auditioning for a
future companion role number 7 the
wedding of River Song and the silliness
of fixed points in space and time
despite being such a science fantasy
story this episode was utterly silly the
wedding itself was not my most favorite
moment it was the sherlock montage as
well as the happy ending that River Song
got River Song seems like the only one
who ultimately gets a happy ending if
you consider her final version to be the
wandering forest of the dead she
actually seemed pretty happy with the
way things turned out I think the
doctor's endings are always rather
ambiguous the ending of the 50th
anniversary was hopeful but you knew
that number 9 would still have to live
with all that guilt so it wasn't
completely happy so I feel like the
ending of the Christmas special the time
of the doctor will be hopeful but it'll
be so sad that you'll have a hard time
celebrating number 6 nightmare and
silver and the Cybermen reveal this was
Neil Gaiman's second Doctor Who episode
and even though it doesn't hold a candle
to the doctor's wife the reveal of the
Cybermen was so much fun it's a perfect
metaphor for what life with the doctor
is like you're constantly presented with
these new shiny things each more
interesting than the next but every time
you pull the curtain back or unwrap that
present it turns out to be your worst
nightmare
I feel like Doctor Who always works best
when it balances science fantasy comedy
and horror in equal parts remember that
Steven Moffat quote traumatized
generation that's what it's all about
number five let's kill Hitler and Matt
Smith's Hail Mary save what I love most
about the final act of this episode was
that he really saved the day by showing
melody that the story of their lives was
a comedy and not this doomed tragedy
that she'd been brainwashed to believe I
consider her melody in this episode just
because she hadn't quite become River
Song yet it was actually in that moment
that we watched the transformation of
this psycho melody into the silly river
song that we all know and love the
doctor probably did not have to change
into that tuxedo to save the day what I
love about the doctor is is that any
time he thinks it's the end he always
tries to go out like a true showman
which is why I cannot wait to see the
final curtain call during the Christmas
special number 4 Vincent and the doctor
a pile of good things and bad things
this is one a doctor who's most cry
worthy episodes
I love how doctor who plays with famous
historical figures to teach us these
existential parables life is a pile of
good things and bad things you can
really take that lesson with you
wherever you go the episode also reminds
you that despite all the sidestepping in
episodes like the wedding of River Song
there are certain fixed points in space
and time that cannot be changed Vincent
has to die and so does the doctor number
3 amy pond's farewell and the Angels
Take Manhattan this for me in recent
memory was the most heartbreaking
goodbye the show has ever had at least
just speaking from series 1 to now
Eccleston and Tennant said goodbye
several times and it was always
heartbreaking but it was usually under
much less drastic circumstances and
usually it was they who were leaving not
their companions you're totally welcome
to present a counter-argument to this
but I feel like after this episode you
feel like Amy loves Rory more than any
other companion loves anyone else on the
show you could say that Rose Tyler's
love for the doctor is a close second
but an alternate version of her got to
keep hand doctor so she didn't quite
make the sacrifice that Amy Pond made
number 2 the 2012 Christmas special I
never know why I only know who it's
always implied the despite the way he
acts or misleads you the doctor
ultimately always has everything figured
out but when he gave Clara the key it
really added this mystical quality to
the show like even though the doctor is
a man of science he also has a lot of
faith not so much faith in the sense of
religion as evidenced by his war against
the church just faith in the sense of
this really unknowable purpose and my
number 1 Matt Smith moment the doctor's
ultimate wish fulfillment made reality
the doctor's wife giving the TARDIS a
face will go down as one of Neil
Gaiman's greatest acts and one of the
most fun episodes of Doctor Who of all
time this is like a reverse 11th hour
story in a sense Amelia pond wish the
doctor into existence twice technically
if you count the first episode and the
time during the Big Bang but this time
the doctor's greatest wish is granted no
matter what River Song or queen
elizabeth's say the doctor married the
TARDIS first my favorite moment from
this as well as my favorite Matt Smith
moment ever was when the TARDIS told the
doctor that he had it all wrong she
stole him it makes you feel like Doctor
Who is really the TARDIS story and the
doctor is just passing through it this
might be the greatest mindfuck of all
but the TARDIS actually really does not
change that much it
this in all of time and space
simultaneously the doctor changes in
much more prominent ways left to change
from Eccleston to Tennant to Smith and
now to Capaldi so maybe we really are
seeing Doctor Who from the TARDIS's
perspective so much to rethink about the
way I view Doctor Who now but let me
know what your favorite Matt Smith
moment is in the comments below
like I said Sunday I'll be doing a week
of Sherlock and Doctor Who video a lot
of year on best list be sure to check
back this weekend for some fun stuff too
right now click here for my breakdown of
the Christmas special and click here for
my top ten moments on arrow this season
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight
high fives
you